in the modern world you can enter a bank
deposit money
travel halfway across the planet and
retrieve that money no issues
but could you do this in the past and
with that how did banks work back then
now banking hasn't changed all too much
throughout european history and as such
we're going to focus on the late
medieval early renaissance period for
two main reasons
one renaissance banks operated across
borders in different states with
different laws and two
the catholic church expressly forbid the
act of charging interest on loans a
practice known as usury
which is what we'll begin with so since
a banker couldn't charge interest on a
loan how did they make profit and why
bother loaning money out at all
well banking families like the medicis
weren't fools and they managed to get
around
interest in two ways the first was via
late payment fines
whilst you couldn't charge interest at
say 10 percent you could find someone 10
percent of the total of the loan if they
were late in their payments
if you were to say payback alone on time
you'd get no fines but in return you'd
likely be blacklisted by every banking
family in existence
and so if you ever wanted another loan
again you'd need to pay it back
late the second way they got around
interest was via currency conversion
you'd get out a loan which would be
provided in one currency
and you'd then pay it back in a
different currency at a different time
and thus
at a different exchange rate the bank
would then pocket the difference
the exception to these rules were kings
and the pope who just got the loan for
free because please don't kill or
excommunicate me
now as the process of taking out a loan
suggests she'd be taking out and paying
back money
in different places meaning that these
banks had multiple branches
as the medicis did so how did these
banks confirm details and prevent fraud
between the different branches
why couldn't someone simply forge a note
saying that they have an account and
then run off with the money
well there were several checks and steps
to verify information
as many of you will know banks at this
time were run by families and members of
these families would be sent to the
bank's branches to run them
these branch managers would know each
other quite well and importantly know
each other's handwriting well too
the bank would then use their own
trusted messengers who would travel as
fast as they could to the numerous
branches to update them on account
information
thus it was possible for a person to
deposit money in say florence and
withdraw it in paris
for a fee that is now all of this was
very profitable but this didn't stop
most banks from going bust very quickly
and this was mostly down to warfare
kings needed money for wars and having a
branch in a kingdom meant that you were
obligated to lend money to the king if
they needed it
and this led to kings taking advantage
of banks since they had near absolute
authority they could
and did simply refuse to pay the loan
back in fact kings were often pressured
by their own merchants and lords to do
so
since this would then force a bank to
default and close meaning that it
couldn't collect payments from anyone
else
and so that's an extremely simplified
way of how medieval banking worked
despite the lack of modern technology or
the ability to charge interest banks
were extremely profitable however it was
an extremely risky business two and
families were often taken down by kings
as quickly as they rose up
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker the
pastry section marvin cassell rob
waterhouse moe
aaron the white james castaneda danny
maloney jordan longley marcus arsenault
gustav swann jerry lambton john bailey
spinning three plates
rasheed ali calling castleman david
silverman izzy
coppertone maggie paxkowski winston
cayward lexy schwinn spencer lightfoot
robert wedzill fortunate calf anthony
beckett and skye chappelle